okay here's one of those things that
really is a huge deal and I want to tell
you how big of a deal it is but I don't
want to seem hyperbolic but it actually
is a really big deal so it's important
to communicate how big of a deal it is
and I'm talking about the census the
Trump administration has now missed the
deadline to print the census forms now
this is an attack on one of the
fundamental institutions of our country
every 10 years there's a census we count
every one the information is used to
make really important and influential
decisions about how funds are
distributed how congressional districts
are reallocated really important stuff
that affects our country for a full
decade until the following census and
you might remember you know when the
right was talking about Obama's not
going to leave the White House in 2016
Obama's going to declare martial law and
suspend the 2016 election it is
counterproductive bottom-feeding
garbage conspiracy crap and we were
right to ignore it from the left when
Trump says he's possibly not going to
accept election results be it 2016 or
2020 or whenever those are really
disturbing possible attacks on our
democratic system but as I've said
before I can't think of any way in which
Donald Trump would be able to
successfully carry out not leaving the
White House if he loses in 2020 but the
census is the census and it is a huge
part of what we do as a country and we
don't have to speculate about what the
Trump administration is doing because
they're doing it right now it's not they
might do it at some point in the future
I've been telling you for years the 2020
census is coming up when we think about
the 2020 election remember we're also
going to be doing the census in 2020
Republicans got to draw districts in
2010 they know the importance of the
2020 census I've been warning you for
years now that the census is underfunded
for a while there was no census director
I actually don't even know if there is
now a census director and then the Trump
administration started talking about
let's put a citizenship question in the
census clearly meant to dissuade even
legal immigrants from participating
which helps Republicans by undercounting
minorities and shifting funds
in ways that are advantageous to
Republicans and they're continuing to do
it they are now citing this disagreement
about the citizenship questions legality
the Supreme Court recently said as as
conceived you can't include the
citizenship question the Trump
administration says yes we can and now
they have missed their own deadline of
July 1 the first day of the month to get
the paper forms printed for the 2020
census and in fact the forms haven't
even been approved by the White House at
this point in time the Office of
Management and Budget OMB is in charge
of this now if you're thinking
critically and I hope that you are you
would already realize it is a huge
problem for something as important as
the census forms to be controlled by the
White House at all the head of the OMB
is Trump's acting chief of staff Mick
Mulvaney Mick Mulvaney gets to decide if
and when the census forms are printed in
principle the census is supposed to
start in five months it starts in Alaska
okay and then it moves on to other parts
of the country during 2020 Trump now is
looking quote very strongly at delaying
the census altogether which increases
the chances that it doesn't get done on
time or at all or fully or properly or
whatever you want to consider is a
possibility of what will happen here so
this is a real attack on our own country
now Obama's gonna declare martial law
there was never any chance of that it
never happened Trump won't accept the
2020 results well maybe he will try not
to I believe that if he loses he will be
removed this is going on right now okay
I wouldn't put it past this
administration to just go ahead and
print the census forms with the
citizenship question no matter what the
supreme court says because this is an
administration that has gotten away with
basically everything yeah some people
are in prison because of things they did
in connection to Donald Trump's campaign
and his administration but this is one
of those things where you know the
Constitution doesn't outline any
specific punishment or Consequences
for mishandling the census once again
much like Robert Moeller said in his
report there are other remedies
available to lawmakers meaning it would
be up to our lawmakers to say wait a
second a president delaying a census for
political reasons that's impeachable in
our assessment more than likely missing
this deadline is not incompetence
although there's plenty of incompetence
to go around it's part of the plan and
they're getting away with all of it okay
quite simply if we don't vote this
corrupt family out all of this continues
and on balance they're going to get away
with it evanka right in there at the g20
having no business being there
whatsoever they're getting away with it
violations of the Hatch Act Kellyanne
Conway ignoring a request to appear
before Congress because of her
violations of the Hatch Act no
consequences obstruction I mean listen
we already talked about obstruction are
we actually going to say there aren't
going to be consequences here and if I
understand Republican elected officials
refuse to hold Donald Trump accountable
then we've got to hold those Republican
elected officials accountable meaning
they must be removed in 2020 whichever
ones are up for re-election meaning you
know members of the house and only
one-third of the members of the Senate
but it's not even clear that Republican
voters are interested in holding them
accountable so I I don't even know how
to put a positive spin on this but what
I can tell you is all of the
hypothetical attacks on the systems that
we believe to be important foundations
of how the United States works including
the census the attacks are happening
right now we don't have to hypothesize
we know what they're doing it's
disgusting it's vile there should be
consequences I'm not confident there
will be let me know what you think I'm
on Twitter at D Pakman the show is on
twitter at david pakman show today's
sponsor is Skillshare and i'm excited to
tell you that everybody in our audience
is getting two entire months of free
access to Skillshare when you click the
link underneath this video skills fairs
the site that offers over 25,000 online
courses on almost any topic you can
imagine cooking meditation
in photography video editing Photoshop
managing a small business almost an
endless list and whether you're trying
to get ahead in your career maybe you
want to learn new skills that will make
you better at your job you might just be
exploring a new hobby and you're trying
to find new ways to be creative in your
personal time skill shares the perfect
place to fully immerse yourself in
whatever you're trying to learn I really
enjoyed the class on more advanced video
editing techniques because it's
something I've been wanting to improve
at but have been very busy hosting the
david packard show for the last few
years
once again the david pakman show is
giving you two whole months of access to
every single class offered by Skillshare
after those two months if you want to
keep your subscription Skillshare super
affordable at less than ten bucks a
month get better at whatever it is that
you're passionate about or discover
something brand new that you didn't even
know that you would love and join skill
shares other seven million users by
clicking the link underneath this video
[Music]